tomorrow the Prime Minister will make a
big speech setting out to the UK's
position ahead of trade negotiations
with the EU joining us to discuss this
from central London is the foreign
secretary Dominic rod but just start if
it's okay mr. Rob with the news this
morning that a small group of Britons
who didn't make it onto that first
evacuation flight from Wuhan the city at
the center of the corona virus outbreak
are now understood to be returning to
the UK what more can you tell us about
that well of course we had the first
flight on Friday with 83 UK nationals
returning to the UK forty-one others
including Europeans and it's a good
example of how even though we leave the
EU will still continue a lot of that
important cooperation and it's correct
that there is a further French flight
that is expected back in Europe today
and that will carry some UK nationals
and I'm very grateful for the
cooperation that we've had first of all
with the Spanish foreign minister but
also the French authorities and as I
said it's a good example of how even
though we'll even the EU will be
cooperating with our friends and
partners very effectively can you
confirm how many British nationals are
on that flight and also why they weren't
on the first flight that the UK pass on
well I can't confirm the precise number
we'll see where as they come into the UK
but the challenge has been immense
you'll know that the cuvette province is
9 times the size of Wales we had a job
to do to get permissions for the charter
flight going in then the permissions to
get the roadblocks eased for the UK
nationals to get to the muster points we
had four coaches put on and we delayed
the original flight by three hours on
the tarmac to try and make sure if many
people could get out that wanted to get
out and obviously as this flight with
the French in shows will continue to
work for those who didn't make the first
flight to give them the cooperation the
support the reassurance that we can help
them as best we can and what will happen
to these people when they do reach the
United Kingdom and they're coming
Enterprise Norton well they'll go to the
arrow Park facility and all of the
protections the support that they need
for the 14-day period will be put in
place so they'll be treated very well
and of course the reason we need to do
that is on the one hand we want to get
the UK Nationals that want to leave
China out on the other hand we need to
make sure we control and prevent the
spread of the corona virus because of
the implications that would have so
that's the approach and the plan that
we've put in place and we've also you're
working with all of the NHS authorities
and the Department of Health and the
health secretary okay thank you for that
and update I'm keen to move on to brexit
because of course this is our first show
now that we have officially left the
European Union and Boris Johnson's can
be giving a speech tomorrow where he's
gonna be setting out some of his
priorities ahead of those trade talks
we're expecting him to say there'll be
no alignment and no concessions what
does that actually mean I mean are we
going to be following any rules well
this is a great crossroads moment we're
leaving the EU it's a moment for a nool
a moment for change we're excited about
the opportunities of exit but also the
wider agenda to level up the country
that's why we're in the northeaster
cabinet on Friday and in relation to
what the Prime Minister will set out I
mean the reality is we've got a deal
with the EU it sets out the political
declaration for the future relationship
and the points you made are well known
we taken back control of our laws so
we're not going to have high alignment
with the EU led to alignment with their
rules but we want to cooperate and we we
expect the the EU to follow through on
their commitment to a Canada style free
trade agreement and that's that's what
we're pursuing and there's great
opportunity here for win-win we're
leaving departing the EU but it's
certain point of departure not the point
of arrival there are huge opportunities
with our EU friends but also global
opportunities and I'll be traveling to
Asia to Australia to Japan to Singapore
next week because of those as well just
to focus again on the briefing around
the Prime Minister's speech no alignment
no concessions I mean it seems pretty
clear that the government is
prioritizing sovereignty over its own
laws and rules over frictionless and
trade access potentially to that market
I mean what this means is custom checks
at the border and paperwork for business
isn't it
now don't think so but look if you look
at things like regulation I don't think
we should be defensive about it when it
comes to the minimum wage when it comes
to maternity leave when it comes to
environmental protections for example
the restrictions here in the UK on
single-use plastic are regulations and
our standards are higher but um can we
assure ieu friends and partners we will
not be insisting that they align with
our rules of the price of a free trade
deal with the UK that's not the way
through trade bills are done globally
and I'm sure that we you'll want to
adhere to their commitment to a Canada
style best-in-class free trade agreement
and there's great opportunity there on
all sides I mean clearly you can say
that it's a price worth paying for
sovereignty but I think it's important
to be honest about what not aligning
with the EU means it does mean custom
checks at the border doesn't it it
doesn't mean paperwork for business but
these been very clear about this we've
got their deal you can examine the terms
it's not my word or anyone else's word
and the commitment is to avoid all of
those things with a best-in-class free
trade agreement and I'm sure and we're
committed to on our side and I'm sure
that you'll want to stay committed to
the the undertakings that they've made
that's what we expect that's what
negotiation is all about but if you're
not aligning with the EU then that does
mean checks it does mean paperwork it
doesn't mean bureaucracy it doesn't mean
cost for business and frankly it
probably means job losses as well well
it would be I think a step backwards by
the EU in terms of the undertakings
they've made but we've been clear it'll
either be a Canada Star best-in-class
free trade agreement or something looser
like the Australians have this 2008
economic partnership framework but our
commitment the agreement that we made
with it was to avoid all of that and I'm
sure that they'll want to live up to the
undertakings they've made just as we've
expect to do the same in the political
declaration if you look at it's very
clear that we would maintain Democratic
control over all regulations but of
course there are global standards that
we entirely expect to live up to and as
I said we expect to be a leader
environmental standards and workers
rights and of course you know the
unemployment in the UK is half the level
it is in the eurozone so we shouldn't be
defensive about this and I'm sure
there'll be some posturing on the EU's
side but but actually there's a great
opportunity
for win-win deal we've got the political
declaration and I think all sides should
put the meat on the bones if you like to
get that done that was the that was the
understanding when we did the deal
withdrawal agreement and I think all
sides should live up to it wonder if I
can detect a bit of frustration on your
behalf director to the EU we're told
that the government's privately
infuriated with the EU for apparently
changing the terms of the deal what
exactly does that mean are you angry it
will keep our cool during these
negotiations I think we've learnt a lot
from the experience of the deal that
we've done the withdrawal agreement but
what we're not going to do is have the
same dynamic where we're told that there
are red lines that must shift and this
that and the other the the issue of
alignment the one that you've raised
with me is just not gonna happen it's
not been it's not the question of being
red lines it's not a negotiating table
it's not even in the negotiating room
and that was the common understanding
that the sign of the draw agreement and
we said that it was Donald Tusk Michel
Barnier said to me that once we'd sorted
out the Norden island protocol once we
got the withdrawal agreement the offer
by the EU was a kanay gist Canadia plus
style agreement well obviously we expect
them to live up to those commitments so
I don't think it's a question of
frustration we will hold them to account
for the undertaker's they've made and
will live up in good faith and with a
good spirit of optimism of goodwill to
get that deal done I wonder if there's
an issue though in the terms of the
relative sides of the UK and the EU at
liriko the Irish prime minister said
this week the UK has yet to come to
terms with the fact it's now a small
country he went on to say that they use
got a population in a market much bigger
than the UK's so if these were two teams
up against each other playing football
who do you think has a stronger team is
he right the rocker is in the midst of a
shall I say very competitive election in
Ireland and I'm not going to interfere
in Irish politics and I'd probably
suggest that he wants to refrain from
doing the same actually we got a good
buy that relationship with the Irish we
just worked together really well to
restore the Northern Ireland
executive that's really important I'm
sure all of that cooperation will
continue and for the UK as a whole even
in you it's as I said a point of
departure not the point of arrival but
we're excited this is about bringing the
country together now we want some unity
going forward and it's about the
optimism the ambition of what and as a
nation and as a country and all the
nations of the United Kingdom can
achieve and we've apologized having
optimistic for the future we're talking
to you our Arlene Foster a little later
on the show at the First Minister
Northern Ireland
if you don't want to align with the EU
that's going to mean custom checks in
the Irish Sea it's going to mean issues
for Northern Ireland isn't it so right
to be upfront with people well no
because of the deal we've done with the
EU we've we've ended the the risk of all
of those worst-case scenarios all those
disruptions we want to make sure that
and I'm sure they will be Irish and
there you will live up to the
commitments they've made and we're
committed to it and of course Norden
Island will leave the EU with the United
Kingdom will avail itself of not just
the seamless trade with the UK but with
the rest of the EU and we'll have the
opportunity to be part of the global
free trades we're doing through trade
agreements we're doing and as I said to
at the outset I'm gonna be off next week
to Asia to Australia to Japan to
Singapore into Malaysia and there are
huge opportunities four quarters of the
United Kingdom with the liberal
energetic and ambitious approach to free
trade we're going to do and that I could
further remember the businesses in this
country it's just gonna cause you is it
means more choice I just wanna come back
on the issue I just want to come back on
the issue of checks because if the UK
decides to diverge if you don't want to
reline with the EU there will be checks
I'm not saying whether that's right or
wrong whether it is a price worth paying
or not but it's just worth being upfront
with people isn't it no it's directly in
conflict not just with the withdrawal
agreement that the undertakings in the
political declaration so of course we
expect those assurances and those
agreements to be kept - that's why we've
done this deal it's a package but the
point I was making is I think we need to
put the relationship that the UK has
within you in the wider context of the
agenda we've got say when Michel Barnier
says there will be chat that's really
important he's right that's really
important but so ever global of
particularly in the asia-pacific region
massive growth opportunity for the
United Kingdom just to talk about check
so so when Michelle Barney who says
there will be checks he's wrong as he
yes
okay's wrong if the EU lives up to its
commitments on its side both in the
withdrawal agreement but also the
political declaration now according to
the Sunday Times you've ordered British
diplomats to sit separately from the EU
counterparts at international summits I
just wonder because on foreign policy it
feels to me is if the UK's got very
similar positional most of the major
issues to our EU allies whether it's new
why away the Iran nuclear deal policy in
the Middle East is this about posturing
rather than policy no it's simply for
example in the WTO will have separate
independent membership of course will a
certain UK position vastly ambitiously
and optimistically but you're quite
right we'll continue to cooperate with
our European partners and friends and
whether it's on the Iran nuclear deal
and triggering the dispute resolution
mechanism which my cooperated very
closely with my French and German at
opposite numbers or in relation to the
coronavirus flights coming back and I've
cooperated very closely with the French
authorities and my Spanish opposite
number of course all of that cooperation
will continue but we will speak for the
UK Fein Pullum for the UK interest just
as other members of the WTO or other
organizations do I think that's natural
that's exactly what people expected as
we need to EU and I think it can be done
not in an adversarial way but in a
confident and ambitious way okay now I
just want to move on to the case of
Harry Dunne the teenage motorcyclist
killed in a road accident the woman who
the police wanted to charged with his
death the driver has fled to the u.s.
claiming diplomatic immunity now you met
with the US Secretary of State might
Pompeii this week did you raise this
case with him and what did you say
oh yes I believe in fairness
Mike Pompeo a policy a positive exchange
event which all the media came to talked
about it as well and we made it very
clear on behalf of the UK we want to see
justice for Harry Dunne is fair
we think answer coolest needs to come
back and face justice when we were
committed to the arrangements being put
in place to make sure that kind of case
could never happen again and as we've
always said we've got a good
relationship with our American friends
and allies and we'll always talk
honestly about these issues because
they're incredibly important and I of
course met their Dunn family in advance
of that meeting because I want them to
have confidence that we're taking up
this case and all the aspects of it in
the candid way that they would expect I
mean you sound very calm talking about
this but so far the u.s. is just
blithely ignored all our requests and
entreaties on behalf of the family of
this dead teenage boy and the Dunn
family has said recently a spokesperson
for the Dunn family said that you're
incandescent with rage over the case are
you angry
we are frustrated with us I want to see
justice for frustrated or angry
well I'll choose my words carefully and
obviously I'll met with the family and I
totally understand the acute frustration
that they feel there are two aspects
there's the case and we want an answer
Kunis to come back in the Home Office
and the CPS have put in the extradition
request so that track is there we're
obviously pursuing that at the same time
they're a whole range of measures that
we want to put in place to make sure the
case like this could never happen again
and we're pushing rigorously on behalf
of the family but also other people in
this country who would expect us to do
that and then just finally we are
looking at HS to the high-speed rail
link a little later on the show good
report that will be showing how we're
expecting a decision on that soon from
the government and Boris Johnson
appeared to let slip earlier this week
to ten-year-old
on Sky's fYI children's program that
potentially construction was going to
keep going he said in a hole the size of
a chess to you the only thing to do is
to keep digging so should we be reading
into that that the government's about to
give a chess to the green light where'd
you say we've got a review underway
we're looking at all of the aspects to
it in terms of value for money but the
connected
the crucial issue about making sure the
noise that North is joined up and can
tap into all the opportunities and I'm
not going to prejudice or preempt the
decision that we made for me shortly
okay
Dominic Rob thank you very much for
being on the program the smaller story